ragazzi avete tutti aperto il video
pensando che mi fosse inventato questo
titolo invece non gioco si chiama the
padre de padre the mother and the two
sorella a larino
come fai a chiamare gioco del padre va
bene che conferma l'ex co
ragazzi siamo tutte padre gioco indie
non italiano pro spianate padre perché
lui è un padre nel senso proprio di un
frate un uomo di chiesa ha capito quello
di minecraft in realtà è una situazione
un po particolare perché quest'uomo io
non ho mai visto e pelato però inizia
una nuova partita almeno ci spiegano che
cosa vogliamo fare il suo gioco
salve signor padre sì però sono metti
sottotitoli non capisco però
schiacciando il tasto permette di
sottotitoli ho saltato l'inizio quindi
ottimo devo mettere i sottotitoli
perfetto non ci sono è un tasto fei ti
sembra e giocherà scp però persone un po
più horror
lo so cestra nostro gioco come grafica
padre alexander
abbiamo urgentemente bisogno di
intervento altro il cursore è una croce
va ben poco piena visione di prodotto
della chiesa la sua ultima posizione
conosciuta nei pressi del delta del
mississipi padre luca ma signor luca
viscusi tanto che padre che c'è una
motosega ho preso una chiave bene ma io
ho visto solo che a una motosega qua
dentro sto padre signor padre non è
normale posso prendere la chiave per
usarla per aprire la porta perfetto
signor padre de padre bene allora mi ha
attirato il titolo di questo gioco non
il gioco in sé il titolo poi dal titolo
capiamo dove si sta andando male dice se
in una villa abbandonata stai facendo
come se fossi a casa tua
ma vai via sono in una villa abbandonata
non so perché ma mi sembra familiare o
troppo dei fiammiferi perfetto posso
andare via di qua per favore
sento una porta a bussare qualcuno sta
bussando ma non è neanche casa mia
quindi io mi faccio i fatti degli altri
permesso trovata una bambola perfetto ho
trovato una medicina c'è anche qualcuno
in questo gioco incredibile potrebbero
farmi del male
salve price a noi un morto a millesimo
in una donna zombie sta leggendo una
ninna nanna ma a chi
ma non è tanto quello perché c'è una
donna bombe gli usa nella bibbia amico
mio vabbè senta sorella faccia pure io
vado via continui a fare io non la
disturbo queste persone a una brutta
abitudine di chiudere tutto a chiave
wipe semi entrasse un padre pelato in
casa a caso anche io le chiuderei
provola un altro discorso
i domini andiamo avanti billeri nella
baia ho messo ho messo aiuto ho messo la
bambola ii e sul letto e la tipa si è
alzata incavolata che dicendomi
ricorrere però poi seri seduta
io credo che questo gioco sia fatto da
dei cannati però è fantastico il fatto
che si agita trovare una chiave che apre
sicuramente una liste porte spero questa
no scherzavo spero l'altra buona non sai
cosa chi apre è possibile che offra il
cassetto
infatti è la pa come ha appena detto è
vuoto e poi ho trovato uno specchio ma
la dave stupido e anche una campana
perfetto la campana sarà sono due volte
teoricamente arriva il maggiordomo jazz
o ciò ho fatto qualcosa occhio sta
entrando voi il maggiordomo da voi che
parte lo sono tre volte la campana si è
aperta con la portali vista uomo stage
l'ex co mamma mia che ansia soggiorno
mamma mia non mi è giocata a roma così
vi giuro non c'è un'ansia assurda piede
di porco gordon posso picchiare la gente
ci sono i ragni sto gioco vi prego
l'ultima cosa che volevo i ragni ma dai
ragazzi che devi per i giochi di non
essere più eco aracnofobia ho spaccato
l'aracnofobia sembra questo gioco sia
stato scritto apposta per me guarda meno
male comunque o il piede di porco tutto
team a girarti quanto vuoi tanto
l'importante è che io apra la porta non
di qua c'è la botola in realtà la
batosta di sotto quindi di qua
vamos aprista porta scatola martellante
che senso cosa me ne faccio ma io che
dici se lo faccio fuori tipo menando lo
posso anche menare la gente guardia
stupida da mia mano quella lì che si
gira quando la guardo da mia mano porco
demonio è morto riposa bene ti aperto
quindi posso entrare qua non armati e
basta ma non si può entrare
una colla mamma mia ragazzi ma garanzia
notato una collana per terra
rosario rotto che devo trovare il
vecchio ma c'è la lingua del quadro raga
ma il suo gioco quando non guardi le
cose succedono cose ma ti pare che
questa strana sto gioco le cose
succedono quando non guardi in tutto
questo è uscito il tema è uscito satana
dalla cornice però donato disco tipo the
ring questione scp ragazzi questo ce la
faccia del crocifisso scp 666
io comunque ci avrei da bibbia da usare
porca vacca mi sa che muoio
ho fatto una cagata non posso passare di
qua perché muoio lasciamo perdere il
cane di belzebù li altra parte per
favore che tanto è legato al quadro non
può farmi male
il fatto è che non posso passare di là
devo trovare un modulo saper comunque
nei due piani voli qua salve una
sconosciuta con l'attrice che migliora
mi scusi smoking secondo me se le devo
accendere la sigaretta che non riesce a
fumavo essere hai visto l'ho dovuto dare
il fiammifero e datte foco e pericoloso
a darci da soli per un po troppo vistosa
grazie ma si troppo gentile posso
spararle adesso magari ci altri call put
proiettili fantastico preti fucile che
non ho però vabbè o mio dio ragazza non
succedendo cose che non mi so spiegare
vi giuro
devo assolutamente andare al piano di
sopra ma c'è sotto cose non mi toccare
viajar no aia e sono morte non sono
morto mai sporco
credo di non dover andare addosso alla
gente per questo poteva essere chiaro
c'è anche prima ma ci metto un po a
capire le cose
corri provando a elite veloce trota la
candela bene con rincorrere i cori lo
schivato fortissimo bene mi serviva solo
la candela l'ho presa via via via via
via proiettili di pistola perfetto
ora posso sparare alla gente però non
altro al tipo di sopra credo però perché
se ne faranno avanti ines cloud o
intasato lo scarico bene
[Musica]
no no no no allora allora
no non mi fate uscire the ring e dal per
favore padre faccia una preghiera non se
ne può più
aiuto
cosa quasi rotto la porta e forse se se
riesce a spaccare la porta mentre mi
sposto può essere lancia mi qualcosa si
può mamma mia che grande stura lavandino
usalo li hai a zelo pastorale in credi
che gioco ischia gioco emozionane la
ragazza cioè neanche game of thrones mi
dava questa verve va bene ho sfiorato un
lavandino e ho combattuto lo scarico
questo è l'unico di mastro lindo
questi sono gli incubi di mastro lindo
raga
ho aperto una porta completamente
segreta non l'avevo vista mai che pirla
il pozzo di cui parlano le leggende
oddio meno ragazzi veramente the rings
parola youth questo è sicuramente
altissima purissima levissima annunci in
acqua
beh potete usare quella della vasca da
bagno di prima
non ho altro da medicina c'è qualcosa di
scritto ho trovato roba questa casa è un
vero tesoro caranna miei reso la persona
più felice del mondo
sarò il mago più potente di tutti i
tempi se harry potter neppure la morte
potrà farmi quando avrò finito va bene
no e voldemort credo e volte molti che
sta creando york sul siamo nel
ripostiglio del professor piton con le
pulsioni però come se stesso creando gli
horcrux prudente non dovevo fare qua
posso darti una bottiglia di whisky
borraccia piena mai detto che non c'era
quali dentro il pozzo vuoto perciò
riempito la
ora non si sa come sexton ed eva occhio
muoviti rischio di morire perché c'è
qualcuno dietro di me però non si
sorprende ancora astutissimo che sulle
nostre cose borraccia volo trovato
un'altra borraccia niente io vivo di
borracce oggi scoraggiato oh mio dio
sono diventato lo slider man ma come
aiuto sono diventato strano ciò dei
problemi vi crescono ai tentacoli però
vabbè io verrei un po di body di
borraccia per tornare come prima
giusto no ho sprecato una borraccia
benissimo
sono entrato nello specchio non lo so se
questo è l'inferno vico ma di sicuro non
è porta venezia questo occhio occhio
occhio gli sto picchiando col piede di
porco picchiati sono immortale con
questa forma qui però comunque uso al
piede di porco per picchiare la gente
quella un altro discorso
finalmente c'è voluto lo intervistava ce
l'ho fatta sono stati in grado di creare
una trappola per l'energia non ricordo
quale potrebbe essere il mio nome pietro
no ti prego ti prego prima di fini sta
roba di vento scemo
[Musica]